[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue dans notre cycle de
conférences qui s'intitule conférence de
co2 par edf parle en économie neutre en
carbone
je m'appelle frédérique bedos je suis
journaliste fondatrice d'une ong
d'information qui s'appelle le projet
imagine et gêne au grand plaisir de vous
accompagner tout au long de ce cycle je
suis en bonne compagnie puisque à mes
côtés se trouve à thomas olivier
léautier qui représente le groupe edf et
qui à ce titre est bien et mon acolyte
de conférence en conférence est notre
invité du jour jean marc jancovici
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
alors dans un instant je vais vous
présenter en détail mais peut-être
d'abord juste vous dire quelques mots
sur nos masques à les conditions
sanitaires qui évidemment sont strictes
vous connaissez la période que nous
vivons est donc pendant tous tout au
long de cette conférence en fait je vais
garder mon masque parce que l'un et
l'autre vous n'êtes pas si éloigné de
moi que cela
mais comme vous êtes éloignés l'un de
l'autre vous aurez l'autorisation
d'enlever votre masque quand vous
prendrez la parole et donc voilà on va
on va faire un petit peu cette
gymnastique mais c'est pour la bonne
cause
alors jean marc jancovici vous êtes
ingénieur enseignants à mines paristech
on peut dire que vous faites partie du
cercle restreint des personnalités
considérées comme étant experte sur les
sujets relevant de l'énergie et du
climat
vous êtes d'ailleurs membre du haut
conseil pour le climat et vous êtes
associé fondateur du cabinet carbone 4
mais c'est sans doute en tant que
fondateur et président du think tank de
shift project que l'on vous connaît le
mieux la spécialité de ce think tank
portant sur la difficile question de la
décarbonation de l'économie vous êtes
l'auteur de nombreux ouvrages dont celui
qui vient à peine de sortir en poche
dormez tranquilles jusqu'en 2100 alors
quelque chose me dit qu'il ya comme une
touche d'ironie dans cette invitation
collective à dormir
mais avant qu'on ne plonge plus avant
dans votre pensée je vais
vers vous thomas olivier léautier et on
va revoir un petit peu votre parcours
vous avez fait polytechnique les ponts
et chaussées vous êtes passé par le m
haïti de cambridge ios et où vous avez
obtenu un diplôme en génie civil ainsi
qu'un doctorat en économie
vous êtes spécialiste des marchés de
l'énergie en particulier de
l'électricité et au sein du groupe edf
vous êtes chef économiste et vous
diriger l'université d'entreprise pour
le management
alors il est a noté thomas olivier que
vous avez collaboré avec pas mois de
deux prix nobel d'économie dont jean
tirole qui a été récipiendaire de ce
prix prestigieux en 2014
et si je fais allusion à cela c'est
parce que jean tirole fait justement
l'actualité le 23 juin dernier en
compagnie de son acolyte l'ancien chef
économiste du fmi olivier blanchard
il a remis au président de la république
un rapport le bien nommé rapport
blanchard tyrol qui a mobilisé la
matière grise d'une commission
internationale à d'économistes pour
plancher sur les grands défis
économiques de notre monde post co vide
et il apparaît clairement dans les
conclusions de ce rapport que la
question climatique se trouve au coeur
des enjeux de demain comme si on avait
besoin de s'en convaincre davantage le
lendemain même de la remise de ce
rapport soit le 24 juin
une tornade d'une puissance incroyable
s'est abattue ici en europe en
république chacun pour être plus exact
dévastant plusieurs villages sur son
passage
un peu plus loin de nous un autre
phénomène spectaculaire tout aussi
inquiétant un dôme de chaleur qui s'est
abattue sur le canada et le nord ouest
des états unis la population suffoque
avec un mercure qui atteint les 50
degrés alors est ce que c'est pour faire
face finalement à ce contexte qui est
particulièrement anxiogène que le groupe
edf a désiré mettre en place ce cycle de
conférences est ce que c'est bien cela
absolument j'ai déjà enlevé masse
puisque j'ai le droit puisque c'est un
autrement vous allez suffrages alors
absolument le
ces deux événements que que vous
mentionnez sont très importants parce
que il illustre bien la situation
alors le premier événement c'est là
c'est la crise climatique en particulier
au canada et la tornade qui s'est
abattue raluy tchèque qui montrent que
la crise climatique elle est réelle elle
est aujourd'hui elle est présente et
donc c'est pas une élucubration de
chercheurs c'est pas quelque chose qui
arrivera dans 100 ans ou dans 200 ans
c'est quelque chose qui réel il ya une
vraie urgence à prendre des mesures sur
le climat
après il ya le rapport blanchard tyrol
et qui a mobilisé effectivement de
nombreux chercheurs
beaucoup d'américains des européens et
ce qui est intéressant dans le rapport
blancheur tyrol c'est bon ils ont fait
des recommandations d'économistes donc
ils n'ont pas d'opinion sur le climat en
soit c'est plutôt sur comment quelles
sont les mesures qu'on peut mettre en
oeuvre mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
pas pour moi ça a été la réception qui a
eu lieu c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens
qui ont dit ah c'est super mais des gens
qui ont dit ça c'est vraiment pas bien
c'est de l'économie désincarné et je me
dis si on est à un citoyen qu'on assiste
à ces événements si brand sent bien qu'à
un problème on voit qu'il ya des
solutions on voit qu'il ya une grosse
débat autour des solutions qui a
beaucoup de deux tempêtes de tumulte
d'émotion et on est un peu désemparé et
quand on a fait ce cycle de conférences
quand avec alexandre paiera on a dit on
va faire un cycle de conférences on
s'est dit le but de l'opération
c'est de de poser le débat et de dire il
ya rappelé à tout le monde qui a un
problème faire la pédagogie du problème
et dire dans les solutions
il ya des points communs il ya des
objectifs qui sont partagés il ya
quelques différences sur les moyens mais
de faire la pédagogie des solutions et
de l'expliquer d'une façon dépassionnée
et c'est ça qu'on essaye de faire de
clarifier ce débat pour nos concitoyens
parce qu'encore une fois ya une vraie
urgence et c'est pour ça qu'on est très
heureux d'accueillir jean marc qui est
temps d un des pionniers en france de la
réflexion sur le changement climatique
on ne le dira jamais assez c'est un des
premiers à avoir alerté qui a vulgarisé
qui a formé des générations d'ingénieurs
qui leur a expliqué l'urgence et
l'importance du don comme et de très
contente d'accueillir et je remets mon
masque bravo
alors c'est vrai que je crois que vous
vous connaissez bien là et l'autre je
pense qu'il n'est pas faux de dire aussi
que vous partager certains points de vue
mais vous avez aussi certains points de
désaccord ça je pense que ça devrait
rendre les échanges d'autant plus
intéressant alors voici le programme
nous sommes ensemble pour environ une
heure une heure quinze sans doute 1h15
parce que ça va être passionnant
on va commencer par écouter
religieusement notre invité qui va nous
faire un exposé et puis nous vous
laisserons échanger l'un et l'autre pour
pouvoir creuser véritablement les sujets
et enfin et bien on se retournera vers
le public afin de répondre à ces
questions à mon avis elles vont pas
manquer d'être nombreuses elles seront
sans doute consistante et j'en profite
d'ailleurs pour saluer nos amis du
groupe des élus ni for the planet qui
nous font le plaisir de se joindre à
nous et qui vont en fait s'adonner à un
exercice de réflexion collective
donc tout ça est très chouette tout au
long de la conférence dès maintenant
vous pouvez donc nous envoyer vos
questions via le chat c'est très très
simple donc surtout n'hésitez pas et
puis tout à l'heure eh bien on se fera
un plaisir d'essayer d'y répondre
donc c'est parti jean marc jancovici le
micro est à vous vous avez environ 25
minutes on vous écoute
enlevez le masque je peux ne rien dire
et juste savourer le fait déjà là c'est
pas mal très bien donc comme je suis en
face d'un distinguer économistes et
qu'on va parler d'économie je vais aussi
vous parler d'économie mais je vais
essayer de vous en parler
essentiellement 100 euros
vous allez voir qu'on peut très bien
parler d'économie 100 euros alors voilà
on est parti je vais vous parler du
système productif delà des hommes 1 et
donc comme j'ai dit on va commencer par
en parler 100 euros si on prend la terre
d'un point de vue anthropocentrique ou
même pas d'un point de vue entre
opposants très dur est la terre c'est un
grand ensemble qui comporte pour les
hommes des ressources exploitables et si
ressources je vais les mettre dans deux
morceaux distincts que les ressources
renouvelables et les non renouvelables
alors tabler non renouvelables il faut
parler des échelles de temps parce que
certaines choses sont renouvelables à
des échelles de temps longue non
renouvelable à des échelles de temps
courte on va dire que renouvelables
c'est tout ce qu'ils se renouvellent
spontanément à l'échelle d'une vie
d'homme ou moins et puis non
renouvelables c'est ce qui se renouvelle
pas à l'échelle d'une vie d'homme ou qui
mettent tellement longtemps que c'est
pas la peine d'en parler
donc voilà à quoi ressemble à terre car
avec les yeux dans les coins comme
aurait dit coluche au moment où les
hommes apparaissent c'est un ensemble de
ressources alors i'm not respect et
pardon quelque chose qu'il faut préciser
j'y reviendrai plus tard c'est que ces
ressources ne nous ont rien coûté
donc la terre c'est fort mais on n'a pas
payé pour ça on n'a pas payé pour la
formation du soleil 10 milliards
d'années après le big bang
on n'a pas payé pour la première
génération des toiles qui à partir de
seul proton ont fait les 92 éléments du
tableau de mendeleïev donc tous les
éléments centraux sur terre ça c'est
gratuit on n'a pas payé pour
l'apparition sur terre deux continents
d'une atmosphère d'un océan de 30
millions d'espèces vivantes de sols
cultivables et c'est tout c'est gratuit
données gratuite et puis on arrive là
dedans et puis nous on va faire on va se
mettre à avoir une activité productive
alors c'est quoi une activité productive
du point de vue des hommes en fin de
l'humanité c'est je prends des
ressources soit gelée concept
directement soit je les transforme pour
en faire autre chose que je trouve plus
sympathique parce que voilà c'est plus
facile de ne pas faire des tâches de
jaune d'oeuf sur sa cravate avec une
fourchette que avec du minerai de fer
donc se trouve que c'est bien
transformer du minerai de fer en
fourchette lors du point de vue des
hommes la production économique ou pas
du reste
elle se décrit en termes de flux d'une
manière très simple je prends dans les
stocks de ressources
je transforme et j'en fais autre chose
qu'il a plus d'intérêt pour moi dans les
stocks de ressources renouvelables
au début de notre espèce nous sommes peu
nombreux notre prélèvements unitaire est
faible donc on ne change pas le niveau
des stocks renouvelables le stock de
poissons n'est pas modifiée par
l'activité des premiers pêcheurs sur
terre ça change pas grand chose par
contre dès lors comptable dans les
stocks de silex les stats de silex se
mettent à baisser alors ils baissent de
manière imperceptible au début mais
quand même il s et puis à un moment on
va découvrir et je vais longuement
revenir là-dessus ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'énergie et vous allez voir
quand fait l'énergie c'est un
amplificateur de la possibilité de
prélever de transformer en fait c'est ça
l'énergie c'est un amplificateur de
cette possibilité donc une humanité avec
de l'énergie toutes choses égales par
ailleurs prélève et transforme beaucoup
plus qu'une humanité sans énergie mais
encore une fois je reviendrai plus tard
alors on est tout ça est très bien et
puis un jour on découvre que il ya une
partie de notre production qu'on peut
mettre de côté pour augmenter la
production future c'est ce qu'on appelle
le capital donc en gros c'est de la
production qui se détruit pas quand on
s'en sert et donc ça permet d'augmenter
encore une fois la production future
alors on trouve ça très bien on lit la
bible en croyant se multiplient et plus
on est nombreux plus on va prélever et
transformé et avoir deux choses
transformer et moins on a évidemment de
ressources naturelles vierges restantes
et puis à un moment on va devenir
tellement nombreux et tellement
productif que non seulement on a baissé
les ressources non renouvelables
les minerais
le pétrole mais on se met également à
baisser les stocks qui auparavant
étaient renouvelables
le stock de poissons a baissé par
exemple le stock de forêt a baissé donc
un certain nombre de stocks qui avant un
se renouveler tout seul se mettent à
baisser et puis dans cette activité
débridée ont créé des sous produits par
exemple quand je transforme un silex
pour en faire une pierre taillée et bien
j'ai des sous-produits c'est des éclats
de silex dont je ne fais rien du reste
parce que c'est des trucs que j'ai
obtenus en taille en silex
voilà ça s'appelle un déchet des éclats
de silex c'est pas un déchet que la
nature comment d'hier trouve extrêmement
gênant ça reste là par terre et on va
dire que ça empêche personnes de vivre
mais quand on devient très nombreux et
très transformer unitairement et bien la
quantité de choses indésirables associés
à notre production devient extrêmement
importante et elle va avoir pour effet
de dégrader la qualité des actifs
résiduels
donc si j'ai énormément de tannerie et
ben je bazarde énormément de trucs dans
les rivières et ça dégrade la qualité
des rivières restantes
donc ça c'est la représentation de
l'activité physique de l'humanité c'est
ça en fait notre système économique
je prends je transforme et au passage de
cette transformation
je crée des choses que j'ai pas demandé
mais qui sont là quand même qu'on
appelle la pollution et qui vont venir
dégrader les actifs résiduels et la
convention que nous avons choisi
d'adopter il y a longtemps et que nous
avons commencé à théoriser il y a
longtemps c'est que quand on va parler
économie dans ce système là on va juste
s'intéresser aux deux flux que je viens
de cercle et en rouge c'est-à-dire là où
on va avoir des hommes qui sont
intervenus dans le processus qu'on va
payer pour faire quelque chose ou pour
se défaire de quelque chose donc des
salaires et des rentes et donc la
totalité de ce qu'on paye quand on
achète un objet c'est pas la matière de
l'objet que mère nature nous a donné
gratuitement c'est les gens qui ont qui
sont intervenus dans le processus entre
la mine est l'objet et qui à qui on a
payé soit des salaires soient des rentes
d'accord donc le prix où le pib qui est
un agrégat de prix eh bien ce n'est rien
d'autre qu'un flux qui est la
contrepartie économique de notre flux de
transformation donc de destruction de
ressources naturelles qui va de la
gauche vers la droite c'est pas une
comptabilité actif passif donc c'est pas
parce que le pib augmente qu'on peut
dire qu'on s'enrichit pour dire qu'on
s'enrichit
il faudrait que la valeur
conventionnelle additionnel de ce que
nous avons créées soit supérieure à la
valeur conventionnelle négatif cette
fois-ci de ce que nous avons détruit et
donc dans une vision actif passif
le jour où la valeur marginale de la
dernière voiture qu'on a construite est
inférieur à la valeur marginale des
derniers stocks de minerai de fer et de
biodiversité qu'on a détruit pour
construire cette voiture on s'arrête de
faire des voitures et on vit happily
ever after comme dans les contes avec
les voitures qui existe déjà
évidemment c'est pas du tout ça que nous
avons pris comme système est en fait le
système qu'on a pris il postule et vous
allez voir plus tard qu'en fait c'est
même explicite que nous nous trouvons
dans un monde infini dans lequel en fait
le moins de gauche c'est-à-dire la
dotation aux amortissements était
pilonnaient sq quelle que soit
l'activité de transformation et donc
c'est juste pas la peine de s'en occuper
voilà est en fait le drame initial c'est
qu'on continue à fonctionner aujourd'hui
avec une approximation au premier ordre
qui date d'il ya deux siècles
à une époque où notre activité de
transformation étaient cent fois plus
petit aujourd'hui alors dans cette
affaire il ya l'énergie dont j'ai dit
tout à l'heure qu'elle était un
démultiplicateur de leurs activités
alors l'énergie vous savez qu'il ya un
ministre pour ça je pas sûr qu'ils
connaissent la définition de l'énergie
du reste je vais pas vous la donner
aujourd'hui mais je vais vous dire une
chose je vous résume et l'énergie est ce
que c'est vraiment l'énergie c'est ça
l'énergie en fait c'est ce qui alimente
l'exosquelette que nous nous sommes
créées
sauf qu'il n'a pas cette tête là c'est
pas celui là qu'on enfile le matin quand
on part au boulot l'exosquelette que
nous nous sommes créé voilà la tête
qu'il a vraiment c'est le parc de
machines que nous avons installé sur
terre et qui travaille à notre place car
les vêtements que vous portez ont été
fabriqués transporté cousue taille est
stockée par des machines
la tartine beurrée que vous avez mangé
ce matin elle est faite de blé qui a été
sommée récolté transformer transportés
par des machines les vaches ont été
traite par des machines etc
enfin nous vivons dans un monde de
machines est en fait l'énergie c'est la
nourriture de ces machines
alors ces machines en question nous ont
constitué un costume d'iron man qui est
particulièrement puissant parce qu'on va
voir quelques machines que nous avons
autour de nous alors si on prend une
première machine qui nous mêmes on n'est
pas une machine très puissante
vous voyez que si je prends quelqu'un
par exemple qui fait 4000 mètres de
dénivelé dans la journée pas mal 4000
mètres de dénivelé dans la journée si
elle et chamonix au sommet du mont-blanc
ou pour ceux qui veulent rester à paris
c'est faire douze fois la tour eiffel
dans la journée avec les gens on va pas
être l'ascenseur donc vous voyez qu à la
fin de la journée quand même on est
content de manger sa soupe aux haricots
et bien si vous faites ce genre d'effort
vous allez développer un kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique dans la journée si
vous faites ça sur deezer vous avez aux
gens m'auront une puissance moyenne de
100 watts
1 voilà donc vous êtes puissant comme
une grosse ampoule à partir du moment où
vous faites ce genre d'exercice physique
quand même assez intense alors
maintenant je prends un objet aussi
anodin qu un mixeur à soupe
oui le truc qu'on met dans les poireaux
là l'hiver en fête dit tout l'été du
reste on peut faire ça avec des soupes
aux courgettes c'est très bon on met ça
dans la casserole ça fait vite et bien
au moment où vous appuyez sur le bouton
vous avez instantanément quatre
cyclistes qui sortent de la lampe vous
avez une lampe âgées livrées cuisine
quatre cyclistes qui sortent de la lampe
et qu'ils se mettent à pédaler pour vous
parce que la puissance du moteur de
votre petit mixeur à soupe ridicule
c'est 400 watts
c'est à dire quatre fois des paires de
jambes surentraînés qui sont capables de
faire le mont blanc dans la journée si
vous passez l'aspirateur
si vous avez de la soupe partout et bien
à ce moment c'est dix cyclistes qui
apparaissent instantanément où vous vous
appuyez sur le bouton marche/arrêt voilà
ils sortent du néant il se met à pédaler
pour vous pique en vo réappuyé sur le
bouton marche arrêt ils retournent dans
leurs boîtes dans leurs lampes et ils
disparaissent
vous montez un ascenseur comme il y en a
juste à côté d'ici à ce moment c'est 50
cyclistes qui sortent du néant et il se
met à pédaler pour que l'ascenseur se
met en mouvement
soyons un peu plus sérieux le tracteur
dont je parlais tout à l'heure qui vous
a permis de manger votre tartine lui il
est puissant comme 600 paires de jambes
ou comme 90 chevaux attelés donc bien
évidemment ça coûte un peu moins cher
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a fait prenons un
engin de travaux publics
lui il est puissant comme des milliers
de paires de bras et c'est notamment
grâce à ces engins qui aujourd'hui avec
un salaire du bas de l'échelle on peut
quand même s'acheter un logement avec
quelques années de salaire voilà truc
qui était juste impensable avant
l'apparition de ces machines
un camion toute la société dépend des
camions aujourd'hui 100 camions les
villes meurent de faim et bien lui
[ __ ] comme des milliers de fois les
jambes de son conducteur et enfin si je
prends un laminoir industriels comme il
y en a à dunkerque ou à fos sur mer
pour remplacer les deux laminoirs que
nous avons à dunkerque et à fos sur mer
par des gens qui taperait sur la tôle
pour développer une puissance
équivalente
je devrais prendre la totalité des
salariés du privé en france
la totalité des salariés du privé en
france ont une puissance c'est-à-dire 20
millions de personnes sont juste capable
de remplacer deux laminoirs industrielle
qui à l'heure où je vous parle sont
chacun piloté par une personne une
personne oui évidemment plus de monde
dans le laminoir parce qu'il faut la
maintenance le machin c'est une personne
donc les machines que nous avons mis sur
terre en fait ce sont elles qui
travaillent pour nous et l'énergie c'est
leur nourriture c'est leur conquête pour
machines c'est pour ça que c'est si
important dans le système productif que
nous avons bâti et elles ont permis ces
machines de démultiplier la puissance
musculaire de l'humanité par plusieurs
centaines alors je vais vous le dire
maintenant d'une façon très économique
si nous n'avions pas les machines et
donc l'énergie permettant d'alimenter
ces machines sur terre le pib mondial
serait divisé par 100 à 200 voilà c'est
ça que ça veut dire en termes très
clairs
alors on peut voir la conséquence de ce
que je viens de vous raconter sur ce
graphique que je vous montre qui est un
graphique que j'avais commencé par faire
par curiosité il ya une dizaine d'années
puis quand j'ai vu le résultat je me
suis dit vas-y donc c'est frappant est
en fait ce graphique il vous donne année
après année en partant de 1965 en bas à
gauche et en allant jusqu'à 2019 en haut
à droite pour chaque année l'énergie sur
l'axé horizontal l'énergie mondiale
utiliser et le pib mondial sur l' axe
vertical
vous voyez que nous avons affaire à une
droite en fait l'énergie c'est le parc
de machines en service donc plus on met
deux machines en service plus à
d'énergie et plus on produit et d'où
certains économistes qui théorisent la
fin du travail
ouais il y aura la fin du travail tant
que les machines bosse pour nous le jour
où il n'y a plus assez d'énergie
je vous assure qu'on va retrouver le
travail est donc en fait une société
sobre en énergie
c'est pas une société dans laquelle
c'est la fin du travail et la seule
question est de savoir où on part en
vacances une société sobre en énergie
est une société dans laquelle on
recommencera à transpirer
alors cette énergie elle est
essentiellement fossiles
vous avez ici la quantité d'énergie
qu'on utilise sur terre depuis un siècle
et demi enfin on pas nous les machines
et vous voyez que les énergies
historiquement se sont empilées les unes
sur les autres elles se sont pas du tout
substituer donc au bois est venu
s'ajouter le charbon en noir en bas puis
est venu s'ajouter de pétrole orange au
dessus puis est venu s'ajouter le gaz
etc et les nouvelles énergies
nous v'la blackie excitant les
journalistes les politiques et parfois
idf que vous avez tout en haut là sept
petits machins rose vous voyez que ça ne
change strictement rien aux ordres de
grandeur pour le moment alors on pourra
discuter tout à l'heure de savoir si un
jour ça va complètement changer la donne
j'ai quelques doutes je pourrais
expliquer pourquoi l'essentiel des
énergies aujourd'hui utilisé sur terre
sont des énergies dites fossiles tout
simplement parce que c'est des faux cils
et ça fait cinquante ans que c'est des
énergies fossiles qui composent 80% du
mx mondial du reste ici je vous propose
un autre graphique que j'ai fait dans
lequel vous avez de 1965 à 2019 je suis
désolé j'ai parmi les dates en abscisse
la quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise et
en ordonnée les émissions de co2 dues à
l'usagé de l'énergie
ben vous voyez on n'a rien décarbonés du
tout c'est une droite absolument
parfaite
donc nous n'avons rien décarbonés en
matière d'énergie depuis 50 ou 60 ans et
demi la croissance du nucléaire dans le
monde ni la croissance de l'hydro
électricité ni la croissance des
renouvelables non changer
fondamentalement le fait que les
énergies fossiles sont restés à 80% et
alors comme l'essentiel de l'énergie et
fossiles vous avez eu ici le drame des
négociations climat qui est que plus il
ya de co2 puis être pib puis être pib
plus accès aux deux en fait c'est un
rapport de cause à conséquence plus il
ya de machines plus être pib mais comme
les machines consomment de l'énergie
fossile pléiade machine puis à tio2 donc
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas faire plus de
pib avec moins de co2 et mon ma
conclusion après avoir bien regardé la
physique sous jacente de l'économie
c'est qu'on ne sera jamais faire dans
les bon ordre de grandeur pour garder la
civilisation industrielle qu'on a
aujourd'hui on en allant à la neutralité
carbone
donc en gros aller à la neutralité
carbone c'est accepter une récession
structurelles c'est clairement ça alors
là dedans je vais revenir à l'économie
vous avez ici le prédécesseur de
monsieur tyrol qui théorisait l'économie
à une époque où prix nobel n'existait
pas qui je le rappelle est pas un prix
nobel
c'est le prix de la banque de suède
c'est une opé assure la fondation de
belles nobel n'avait pas prévu de prix
pour l'économie il faudra lui demander
pourquoi bon c'est un peu difficile il
est mort mais ils n'avaient pas prévu de
prix et c'est la banque de suède acquis
dans les années 60 a dit non mais ce
serait quand même bien dues au moins en
faire un aussi pour l'économie
donc c'est le prix de la banque de suède
en sciences économiques en mémoire
d'alfred nobel
donc notre ami jean baptiste say grands
ancêtres des deux bébés afin de ducey
d'obédience heures c'est le même à une
époque où on théorise l'économie
classique dit bah voila quand on va
regarder ce qui compte dans la
production économique les ressources
naturelles ça va valoir 0 alors c'est la
conséquence de ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure à une époque il ya deux siècles
il ya beaucoup moins de gens
qu'aujourd'hui on est beaucoup moins
productif parce qu'on a brouillé man
machine en fait ya beaucoup moins une
machine en service et au premier ordre
on peut considérer que le monde est
presque infini face à la modestie de
l'humanité donc les prélèvements qu'on
peut faire de ressources ça change pas
grand chose au stock résiduel de
ressources donc vous savez pour tous
ceux d'entre vous qui ont fait des maths
que une variation fini dans un stock
infinie ces failles variation relative
nul donc on se dit on va pas s'emmerder
à mettre des zéro partout dans les
équations restons à 0 sauf que ça nous a
amené à théoriser le système de façon
permanente comme suit le système
productif a donc deux facteurs de
production les gens qui travaillaient le
capital et 6 gb deux facteurs de
production et bien le supermarché est
rempli et les retraites sont payées
alors au regard de l'économie physique
que je viens de vous exposer moi je dis
oui peut-être sauf que pour remplir le
supermarché il faut les ressources qui
vont permettre de faire les produits qui
permettent de remplir le supermarché et
ça c'est vrai même quand on est dans les
services et moi je suis dans les
services je m'aime des services
totalement inutile tu consultants et
bien dans mes services inutiles j'ai
besoin d'un ordinateur c'est des
ressources tout à fait matériel j'ai
besoin d'un bureau c'est des ressources
tout à fait matériel j'ai besoin de le
transporter dans un rer qui est fait en
ressources tout à fait matériel
j'ai besoin d'un stylo qui est tout à
fait matériel j'ai besoin d'un réseau de
télécoms qui est tout à fait matériel et
j'ai besoin de clients qui eux mêmes
sont dans des flux tout à fait matériel
donc le l'idée qu'on pourrait avoir une
économie tout à fait désincarné au
milieu du vide intersidéral ça marche
pas même pour les services
donc on a besoin de ressources et on a
besoin d'une capacité de transformation
de ses ressources
ça s'appelle le travail du reste en
physique le travail c'est la
transformation est comme gelée évoqué
juste avant ce travail il est fait un
peu par nous et essentiellement par les
machines
alors là pardon il ya également du
capital dans cette représentation le
capital c'est une transformation pare de
rouge les pas me lasser une
transformation de ressources naturelles
comme l'eau
sauf que ça se détruit pas quand on s'en
sert alors ce qu'on voit bien dans cette
représentation c'est que si à un moment
pour une raison voulu changement
climatique ou subi les réservoirs sont
vides
j'ai plus assez d'énergie fossile et
bien même si j'ai des gens prêts à
travailler et des banquiers très
complaisant et du reste on a les deux en
ce moment de façon surnuméraires il ya
du pognon partout on sait plus quoi en
faire donc la valeur de tout et
n'importe quoi augmente jusqu'à des
plafonds totalement déraisonnable les
entreprises les mètre carré parisien les
oeuvres d'art pourquoi on fait tout ce
que vous voulez et puis on a des gens
surnuméraires partout puisque du chômage
partout donc on manque pas des deux
facteurs de production que qui sont dans
la théorie économique
par contre on commence à avoir des
petits stress sur l'énergie et ça ça
fait des stress sur le pib et il suffit
pas de mettre plus de gens au travail
pour augmenter le pib ça marchera pas
comme ça et si on a un stress sur les
ressources par exemple si vous êtes dans
la pêche et il ya plus de poissons à
pêcher pouvait avoir plein d'énergie
plein de bateaux plein de marins et un
crédit maritime très très coopératif
pardon pour le jeune homme s'est pas
pour autant vous pêchez plus de poisson
donc il y aura moins de choses à pêcher
voilà donc ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est
que dans cette représentation de
l'économie physique
en fait si on a une limite très forte
sur l'énergie encore une fois qu'on seul
impose pour des raisons climatiques et
on va évidemment discuter j'imagine de
la possibilité de passer du fossile au
décarbonés mon avis là dessus je pense
que ça sera pas un point dans les délais
si on a une contrainte donc soit pour
des raisons climatiques soit pour des
raisons géologiques
il se trouve que par exemple sur le
pétrole conventionnel la production a
commencé à décliner depuis 2008 et c'est
pas une affaire de climat c'est juste
qu'il y en a plus assez eh bien vous
auriez un stress sur le pib le pib vrai
c'est à dire la vraie production de
biens et de services
là aussi on pourra peut-être en discuter
aujourd'hui une partie du pib est devenu
du pib faut c'est de l'inflation
d'actifs non corrigée dans les calculs
parce qu'on corrige l'inflation des
biens courants mais encore jeu par
l'inflation des actifs quand on fait les
calculs du pib donc si le prix de
l'immobilier double ça fait du pib
virtuel qui est qui est réel dans la
croissance du pib mais qui est
totalement virtuel parce que ça fait pas
plus de mètres carrés pour les pour le
genre lorsque je suis en train de vous
dire avait été théorisée il ya cinquante
ans déjà par une équipe de dynamicien
des systèmes issus du même prestigieux
établissement que thomas olivier c'est à
dire le m haïti
et il avait regardé comment pouvait
évoluer un certain nombre d'indicateurs
macro scopique caractérisant l'humanité
sur une planète finie alors les
indicateurs caractéristiques qu'ils
avaient regardé c'était la population
que sur ce graphique vous voyez ici
envers la quantité de nourriture
produite ce que vous voyez ici en violet
la production de biens industriels que
vous voyez ici en rouge la pollution
c'est à dire les sous produits
indésirables et ça c'est les ressources
restantes
alors nos amis disent au début j'ai un
stock de départ de ressources la
population je démarre en 1900 à la
population et pas très élevé elle a
produit la nourriture j'en produis pas
énormément puisqu'il n'y avait pas
énormément de gens à nourrir etc
et alors que c'est alors le rapport a
été fait sur 12 qu'est-ce qui se passe
alors il se passe qu'au début tout va
bien vous voyez la population augmente
la nourriture qu'on produit augmente la
production industrielle augmente la
pollution augmente pas très très vite et
les ressources ne baisse pas très très
vite donc tout va bien
et au moment où sort le rapport dit du
club de rome non seulement tout va bien
mais il avait théorisé que tout
continuerai à aller bien pour encore un
certain temps
c'est à dire qu'on continuerait à avoir
pas mal de ressources qu'on continuerait
et c'est avec la pollution serait pas
encore dramatique
c'est après qu'on rigole donc ils nous
disent après vous pouvez retourner le
problème dans tous les sens vous pouvez
retourner le problème dans tous les sens
tant qu'on cherche à faire croître la
production économique c'est-à-dire la
produit le prélèvement de ressources
pour la transformer en autre chose
quelque part dans le courant du 21ème
siècle le système s'effondre sur lui
même alors un effondrement c'est quoi
c'est que vous êtes au delà de la
capacité de relaxation du système
il peut plus revenir en arrière après
que vous ayez franchi des seuils c'est
physique ça aussi c'est des trucs qui
sont bien connus en physique et à ce
moment quoi que vous fassiez de toute
façon la population diminue de façon
drastique la production industrielle
diminue de façon drastique la quantité
de nourriture qu'on peut produire sur
terre diminuer de façon drastique
alors si vous avez plus de ressources
vous en consommeraient plus vous êtes
plus tranquille sur les ressources mais
du coup vous pouvez y aurait plus donc
c'est la pollution qui vous turf avons
acquise avait changé les conditions
initiales dans tous les sens et dans
tous les cas de figure il était retombé
sur la même conclusion dans le courant
du 21e siècle
le système s'effondre alors o'shea
project jeu final à des présentations
par là on va essayer pour les prochaines
présidentielles de sortir un programme
économique qui n'est pas besoin de
croissance alors plus exactement on dit
on va sortir un programme économique y
est je joue à l'accord de paris pour de
vrai et l'accord de paris
on devient neutre en carbone en l'espace
de quelques décennies alors si vous êtes
si vous voulez voir ce que ça représente
ça veut dire en particulier que les
émissions sont divisées par trois d'ici
à ce que mes enfants et mon âge donc
dans les 30 ans qui viennent
ça veut dire qu'elle doit baisser de 5%
par an tous les ans à partir de
maintenant 5 % c'est ce qu'elles ont
fait en 2020 à cause du coc vie d'un
donc tous les ans faut faire la même
chose et ça veut dire en particulier à
cause du fait que c'est l'énergie
fossile qui est la pièce maîtresse de la
civilisation terme aux industriels que
nous avons créés ça veut dire que nous
sommes en récession structurelles c'est
ça que ça veut dire
donc nous on va dire va très bien on va
essayer de voir à quoi ça ressemble de
continuer à avoir des jobs de l'espoir
et comment est-ce qu'on organise nos
activités dans un monde où la sobriété
devient le maître mot comment est ce
qu'on fait pour organiser ce truc là et
s'en sortir le moins mal possible donc
c'est exactement ce travail que nous
avons commencé à faire
il sera probablement jamais parfait mais
c'est une base de discussion qu'on va
essayer de poser sur la table à partir
de septembre pour être capable d'engager
un débat que nous espérons adultes sur
le problème que je viens d'évoquer sans
se raconter d'histoires et avec une
approche qui est bouclée hier
qu'aujourd'hui tous les gens qui vous
racontent qu'on va s'en sortir par
exemple a renoué avec les renouvelables
en fait ils font des trucs pas bouclé
c'est de la croissance verte c'est à
dire que le truc se marchent sur les
pieds avec les hypothèses de départ
voilà je remercie
merci beaucoup chaire jean marc
jancovici pour ce brillant exposé c'est
vrai que l'originalité de votre vision
c'est vraiment cette approche avec un
critère principal celui des énergies qui
vous permet en fait de revisiter toute
l'évolution civilisationnel c'est
vraiment ça et donc du coup à bien des
égards c'est très intéressant parce que
ça nourrit notre voilà notre vision par
rapport aux enjeux d'aujourd'hui et en
même temps ça fait froid dans le dos à
plein de niveaux parce que comme vous le
dites voilà on a beau prendre les choses
dans tous les sens on se dit bon voilà
il ya une espèce d'effondrement et
d'ailleurs on se demande si finalement
vous êtes fait partie de ceux qui se
disent collab seul homme mais on va voir
vous allez nous dire parce que je pense
qu'en inde à ma droite qui doit brûlé
d'impatience de réagir l'avesnois sujet
d'enlever de masquer cet hommage
viviez léautier qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce diagnostic de jean marc
jancovici
d'abord je trouve que l'exposé sur la
sur l'histoire de l'économie est
vraiment très bien fait et je trouve que
c'est quelque chose de très clair de
très pédagogique et je suis d'accord
surtout jeux sur l'app sauf sur la
partie des croissance future c'est à
dire que effectivement l'énergie a été
un entrant majeur dans la croissance
économique depuis le deuxième essai
depuis le début du 19e siècle
effectivement l'énergie étant
socialement car donner ça a été d'abord
du charbon puis maintenant c'est du
pétrole et du gaz
en revanche quand nous regardons le
futur quand nous prenons en compte la
l'urgence climatique et l'impératif de
décarbonés notre économie quand on fait
les calculs les calculs c'est pas moi
qui les fais c'est l'ensemble des
chercheurs la r&d d'edf et d'états
d'organisations c'est la banque mondiale
l'agencé internationale d'énergie et là
je parle que de la la partie physique
c'est-à-dire les exos judée exajoules
quand on fait les calculs on se rend
compte qu'on peut faut s'y faire il faut
s'y coller mais qu'on peut décarbonés
notre système énergétique alors ce qu'il
faut faire c'est tout le monde tombe à
peu près sur les mêmes choses et puis
quand on lisait ce que ce que prépare le
chiffre project on retrouve à peu près
sur les mêmes choses il faut faire de
l'efficacité énergétique
il faut décarbonés le transport dans des
véhicules électriques
il faut décarbonés le chauffage donc des
pompes à chaleur plutôt que des
chauffage au fioul enfin il faut
électrifié pardon le transport
électrifier le chauffage
peu après il faut décarbonés la
production d'électricité est là alors il
ya un 'mix' nucléaire renouvelable dans
le renouvelable à plusieurs sources
possibles
une fois qu'on a fait tout ça mais il en
reste un peu et après on fait de
l'hydrogène ont fait du cc du carbone
dans le capture et stockage cc us
quand on met tout ça bout à bout juste
en regardant les exajoules on arrive à
produire suffisamment d'énergie pour
éviter l'effondrement c'est-à-dire pour
maintenir le bien-être à un niveau à peu
près acceptable et c7 c'est cette
conviction qui nous anime nous le df
puisque mon école d ingénieurs on opère
des actifs énergétiques ma part des
actifs industriels donc on dit bah oui
quand on regarde nous on se dit bon on
est capable de les construire n'est
capable de les opérer
il faut changer complètement mais d'un
point de vue technologique nous on y
croit
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'ont reflet dans
notre raison d'être qui est dire
concilier la préservation de la planète
le développement et le bien être à
travers l'énergie et carbone ça c'est le
premier point après quand on regarde les
coûts de cette affaire alors les coûts
effectivement je suis d'accord avec toi
c'est toujours un peu plus compliqué
parce que des hypothèses
on tombe sur 2 5 4% du ppi donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut faire
donc ça jusque là on est assez confiant
là on est moins confiant et je pense qu
on se rejoint là dessus c'est sur la la
capacité collective à se mettre en
mouvement dans le temps qui nous est
imparti dire quand on regarde depuis la
cap 21 qui a été un grand moment les
émissions ont continué à augmenter
elles n'ont pas vraiment diminué dont
elles ont continué à augmenter depuis la
coop 21
on entend beaucoup de déclarations dont
beaucoup de promesses mais on voit pas
beaucoup d'action dont nous il nous
semble qu'il ya un vrai besoin de
pédagogie c'est à dire que la société
civile l'ensemble de la société
s'emparent du problème et pousse pour
des politiques actives vigoureuse de
réduction des émissions du co2 avec les
technologies dont on dispose donc pour
nous c'est plutôt un enjeu politique au
sens vie de la cité au sens conscience
collective quels enjeux technologiques
aucun enjeu économique
il ya une autre chose qui nous inquiète
c'est l'impact plus globale sur la
biodiversité parce que l'on vienne
parler du carbone ce stock fini de
carbone dont on dispose de co2 pour être
plus précis mais au delà du carbone ya
l'impact qu'on a sur sur la pollution de
l'air il ya l'impact net sur les
rivières il n'y a pas que bien sûr les
azotes il ya un ensemble d'impact sur la
biodiversité en général qu'on a sur le
sur le sur l'environnement qui nous qui
est notre planète qui sont l'ensemble
des ressources renouvelables et non
renouvelables et je trouve que la
distinction était bien vu celle de jean
marc ela on est pas vraiment confiant
sur le fait qu'on va ça peut vous savoir
s'emparer de ce problème sur la partie
énergie
on est confiant quant à la technologie
que c'est accessible économiquement
l'enjeu tel qu'on le voit nous c'est la
prise de conscience politique
d'où ce cycle de conférences pour
échanger pourrez partager pour que pour
discuter de ces sujets là jean-marc vous
qui effectivement travailler maintenant
avec le chief project et avec cette
communauté des shifters vous travaillez
donc ce plan de transformation de
l'économie française en
peur du climat et de la résilience ça
veut dire que vous essayez effectivement
d'apporter des solutions est ce que vous
commencez à rejoindre cette vision sur
le fait que c'est possible de décarbonés
l'énergie de trouver non en réaction si
aujourd'hui on avait la même quantité
d'énergie totalement décarbonée il ya
plein de problèmes dont on serait
toujours pas débarrassé pour autant on
continue à empiéter sur les espaces
naturels on continue à la manger on est
8 milliards d'individus mangeant trop
bien donc on déforeste un tiers des 40 %
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre ça
vient pas de l'énergie ça vient de
l'agriculture de la déforestation et
d'autres procédés si tous les bateaux
étaient nucléaire on pêchera quand même
trop donc il ya une pression humaine sur
l'environnement qui ne se limite pas à
la question du co2 par contre elle est
au premier ordre
ram nabeul à la quantité d'énergie qu'on
n'utilise pression humaine donc le fait
que l'énergie se dé carbone en restant
identique en volume ça ne règle pas tous
nos problèmes
donc on est obligé de laver c'est aussi
ce qui montre aussi l'esthétique des
sessions baisse l'énergie on baisse la
quantité de machines en fonctionnement
et donc on baisse le pib vois pas
comment on peut faire autrement
donc je dans les scénarios de place que
j'ai regardé il y en a pas un qui soit
bouclée c'est à dire que le scénario de
l'eeie parfum de l'agencé internationale
de l'énergie par exemple il repose sur
un certain nombre de d'hypothèses qui me
semble relever du conte de fées
la première hypothèse c'est que il
verrait un cadre du plan de l'efficacité
énergétique de l'économie overnight là
c'est sur un siècle on n'a jamais fait
mieux que 1 % par an en tendance longue
et où il passe à 4 5%
je ne sais pas comment mais voilà c'est
alors dans un tableur c'est très facile
de faire 5 % moi je sais faire ça aussi
dans la vraie vie celle où paire de
manches la deuxième chose c'est que on
continue à utiliser des fossiles et on
met de la capture et séquestration du
carbone partout alors pour donner un
ordre de grandeur même si on est un peu
technique
aujourd'hui la masse conjuguées de
pétrole et de gaz qu'on extrait de terre
tous les ans et 7 milliards de tonnes 4
milliards de tonnes de pétrole pro
milliards de tonnes de gaz les dans le
scénario de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie qui nous permet de tenir sous
les deux degrés pour conserver la
croissance ont concerne plein d'énergie
dans des faux cils mai
capture et la quantité de co2 qu'on
capturerait pour remettre sous sol dans
30 ans en trente ans pas loin que ça
serait 9 milliards de tonnes par an
c'est-à-dire que l'on ferait plus que
doubler la taille du secteur oil and gas
juste pour remettre sous terre un
produit qui aujourd'hui n'a strictement
aucune valeur commerciale
pas une seconde un truc comme ça ne va
arriver la quantité de métal qu'il
faudrait produire pour faire les
voitures électriques et les éoliennes et
les panneaux solaires qui lie à dans le
scénario en question suppose de
multiplier la production de nickel par
20 en 20 ans alors je pense qu'ils
ramènent serais ravi mais j'ai quelques
doutes sur le fait qu'on va y arriver et
supposerait de multiplier la production
de cuivre par trois en vingt ans je suis
pareil j'ai quelques doutes sur le fait
qu'on va y arriver et c'est donc en fait
le scénario en question il est
absolument pas bouclé et aujourd'hui je
n'ai jamais vu un scénario de croissance
verte bouclé pin pin donc plutôt que de
prendre un pari qui a toutes les chances
de passes réalisées
o'shea project on a dit nous on va
prendre le pari que on va fonctionner
dans un monde sans croissance puisse y
en a je pense qu'on sera quoi en faire
alors que si on prend le pari que il y
en aura et qui en a pas là on est quand
même un peu coincé parce que on se met
dans une situation dans laquelle la
marmite sociale
explosion donc la façon dont on s'y
prend c'est que l'on raisonne par
secteur on va résonner physique c'est à
dire qu'on va résonner ressources
on va résonner compétences c'est-à-dire
gens donc on va s'occuper des gens et
des ressources et l'économie deviendra
un terme de bouclage c'est à dire que
une fois qu'on sait ce que doivent faire
les gens et avec quelles ressources
on mettra des euros derrière en disant
voilà ce que ça peut représenter en
termes d'euros mais à la limite on s'en
fout s'il faut passer des voitures à
pétrole au vélo électrique c'est ça
qu'il faut faire après que le vélo
électrique vaille 1000 2000 ou 5000 ou
10000 euros c'est pas tellement le sujet
le sujet c'est que les gens en aient un
bon donc le ça peut paraître idiot dit
comme ça mais en fait c'est bien ça
l'important c'est le fait qu'ils aient
envie de s'en servir et qu'ils en aient
donc le on va prendre le problème nous
vraiment sous l'angle physique on va
regarder comment est-ce qu'on doit
physiquement organiser le système et à
quelle vitesse on peut on peut déplacer
le système de quelles compétences on a
besoin pour ça mais prendre un autre
exemple dans la rénovation du bâtiment
si on veut faire un million de
rénovation par an il faut faire rentrer
2 à 300 mille personnes dans l'artisanat
du bâtiment
on les a aujourd'hui donc on les a pas
et on les forme pas du reste parce qu'on
continue à dire à nos chères têtes
blondes à l'école que s'ils sont bons
ils iront à la fac ex ils sont nuls ils
font masson donc il ya il ya plein de
trucs a changé il n'y a pas juste le
fait de trouver le bon prix du carbone
et donc pour rebondir sur le rapport
tyrol tout à l'heure je fais partie des
gens qui pensent que ce truc est
totalement désincarné parce que c'est
fait par des gens en chambre qui sans
jamais poser la question de savoir
comment former un maçon alors que le
vrai problème il est là il est dans
dance dans ce genre de problème pratique
donc haut la façon dont on fonctionne
c'est dans 15 secteurs dans chaque
secteur on va chercher des gens du
secteur avec lesquels on travaille
il se trouve qu'à côté du chiffre
project on a créé il ya une association
qui s'appelle les shifters ou dans
laquelle il ya maintenant dix mille
personnes et donc il ya des gens
compétents techniquement sur à peu près
n'importe quoi donc il suffit de leur
demander suffit de faire un appel au
peuple en disant qu'ils aient envie de
nous aider pour avancer sur tel sujet et
on va chercher donc des gens du secteur
dont qui connaissent très bien les
éléments techniques sous jacent pour
nous aider à faire quelque chose qu'on
peut mettre sur la table sans rougir
donc ça veut pas dire que ce sera
nécessairement complet mais ça veut dire
que on peut le mettre sur la table sans
rougir et qu'on pense qu'on est capable
d'en discuter et on va le présenter à un
public aussi large que possible dont par
exemple des syndicats dont par exemple
des gens à droite et à gauche j'ai envie
de dire prient dans la rue à qui on
demandera ce qu'ils en pensent voilà on
est on est en train d'organiser aussi un
grand système de mise en débat pour
essayer d'avoir un nombre important
d'avis externe que les gens nous disent
ça votre truc c'est complètement con au
contraire oui je comprends bien la
philosophie et enfin je vais finir par
un élément issu d'un sondage très récent
que j'ai vu qui m'a beaucoup frappé on a
demandé à la population française si ils
avaient à choisir entre les deux
affirmations suivantes laquelle il
préférait la première c'est il faut
préserver l'environnement même si ça
doit nuire à la croissance et détruire
des emplois
ou bien il faut préserver à toute force
la croissance même si ça permet pas de
s'occuper correctement de
l'environnement et bien une majorité de
la population y compris dans les milieux
modestes préfère la première affirmation
alors je trouve ça très intéressant et
très encourageant ça veut dire que je
pense qu'aujourd'hui une large partie de
la population est mûr pour penser le
système sous l'angle physique
en dix ans les euros c'est un terme de
bouclage on verra derrière comment on
les organise
voilà et très étonnamment plus les gens
sont vieux puits sont favorables à la
croissance ce qui est quand même un truc
très étonnant puisque c'est eux qui vont
en profiter le moins longtemps mais
aussi un module est alors là c'est très
riche tout ce que vous venez de partage
et jean-marc ce que je comprends c'est
que évidemment vous ne croyez pas au
concept de la croissance verte je crois
d'ailleurs que vous remettez aussi en
cause le développement durable
vous pensez que c'est un non sens et pas
bon sens c'est un oxymore
oui très bien très bien et donc
effectivement vous faites en sorte donc
de mettre en place une force
d'intelligence collective ans pour
travailler sur ce plan est ce que je me
dis c'est vraiment en termes d'espérance
sur quoi on base l'espoir vraiment sur
le quoi on va bâtir cet espoir pour
véritablement se projeter vers un destin
commun qui reste quand même un destin
qui soit attirant pour nous tous et
c'est là où je vois qu'il ya sans doute
donc ce point de désaccord peut-être
revenir peut-être sur tout ce qui a
trait aux énergies renouvelables puisque
vous
croyez vous y croyez moi enfin c'est ce
que j'ai cru comprendre et évidemment
peut-être un peu les pieds dans le plat
et puis après vous mettrez vos nuances
mais je pense que c'est quand même
l'accession on a je pense que encore une
fois on a là il ya beaucoup de points
communs entre la démarche de jean marc
les position que défend jean marc et le
et le ps que nous odf groupe edf ont
pensé puis on fait quotidiennement il ya
une vraie prise de conscience de
l'urgence climatique et ça je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui est peut-être
vrai aujourd'hui qui est peut-être
compris aujourd'hui mais qu'il est
peut-être moi qui l'ait peut-être qu'il
était peut-être moins ya quelques années
et surtout qui a encore gagné même si
effectivement les sondages commencent à
le montrer il ya une vraie conviction
dans le groupe edf qu'on a si urgent peu
plus en parler il faut commencer à faire
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
soit je pense que dans le chili projet
ce que j'ai dit ce que je trouve
vraiment super c'est la partie en fait
travailler beaucoup de gens intelligence
collective parce que je pense que là une
des clés de la résolution du problème
climatique
ça va être là la partie adhésion
collective compréhension par un grand
nombre des gens qui vont sentir impliqué
qu'on souhaite axer leurs problèmes
leurs solutions
enfin c'est super important de même et
on l'a dit tous les deux je pense que la
partie même si on arrivait à résoudre le
carbone ce qu'on espère l'impact sur
l'environnement est vraiment très
troublant et même si on arrive à
produire tous les mégawattheure dont on
a besoin décarbonée il faut aussi faire
attention aux rivières il faut aussi
faire attention à la biodiversité notre
notre problème environnemental va au
delà du carbone donc ça c'est les points
qu'on compare talent pour autant quand
on arrive sur le va pas rentrer en
discussion de chiffres machin truc
bidule sinon on va pas s'en sortir mais
quand on regarde tous les rapports qu en
ligne quand on regarde tout la recherche
que font nos gars j'ai juste parlé de
l'efficacité énergétique nous groupe edf
ont dit on s'est engagé à réduire nos
émissions de co2 de 29 % d'ici à 2030 en
scope 3 donc c'est des émissions de co2
c'est pas des mégawattheures d'énergie
c'est le co2 donc ça veut dire que quand
nous on fait nos calculs on se dit des
taux de décroissance donc 30% et calculs
sont pas si plus des ordres de grandeur
que les calculs pile mais se dire en
moyenne sur 10 ans réduire les
consommations énergétiques chez nos
clients d'à peu près 3% par an nos
ingénieurs de chez dalkia qui sont là
l'usma c'est faisable
donc si tu veux
11 4% c'est peut-être un peu beaucoup
mais 3% ça nous choque pas dans nous on
est pas on est encore une fois quand on
regarde tous les chiffres tous les
chiffres qui sont remis dans ces
rapports les terres d'anti parlent les
possibilités de recyclage les volumes
les espaces etc
on trouve que les chiffres sont pas je
pas choquant j'allais dire sont pas de
déconner mais on peut avoir une
différence d'opinion là dessus
l'autre différence d'opinion quant à
c'est sur l'utilité du prix du carbone
le prix du carbone
c'est quelque chose qui nous permet de
modifier le comportement des gens
aujourd'hui de modifier les
investissements des gens facilement qui
sont aujourd'hui pour demain et en plus
d'avoir de l'argent à distribuer pour
accompagner les gens qui en ont besoin
prendre un exemple tu veux faire un des
plus gros émetteurs de carbone c'est les
mines c'est le charbon fabrique du
christ et avec du charbon fermé
centrales au charbon et à deux
possibilités la première tu dis on ferme
coup de charbon deuxième possibilité tu
dis bah on va mettre un prix du carbone
à 100 euros la tonne 100 euros la tonne
ça fait 100 euros du mégawattheure pour
le charbon
on peut plus produire du charbon 100
euros la tonne tu multiplie par le
nombre de tonnes qui sont échangées dans
les marchés ça fait entre 40 et 50 60
milliards d'euros par an en europe à
utiliser pour donner aux mineurs de
charbon qu'on a mis au chômage pour
donner aux producteurs de charbon qu'on
a mis au chômage pour les refaire pour
les reformer et c'est donc nous la
groupe edf à la fois les scientifiques
l'ensemble du collectif en zee un prix
du co2 c'est pas la solution parfaite
c'est pas suffisant mais si on commence
par faire ça on va tracks youn et sur
des décisions aujourd'hui et ça va nous
donner des financements qui nous
permettront d'accompagner la transition
c'est pour ça que dans le rapport
blanchard tyrol il ya beaucoup de choses
qui effectivement sur la paire abstraite
mais cette recommandation là me semble
très concrète très pratique et très
juste qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
genre d'outil économique
je vais faire une réponse globale
d'abord je ne suis ni pour ni contre les
renouvelables ni pour ni contre le prix
du carbone je suis tout à fait je
maintiens mon jugement sur le fait que
tireront les blanchard sont des
universitaires cet éclair de part du
fardeau
donc c'est des gens qui se frotte pas on
prend une pratique c'est ça que je
voulais dire mutins et dans leurs
commissions ils sont entourés de
personnes se frottant aux problèmes
pratiques
voilà donc
ils ont fait un truc qui est désincarnée
à ce titre sinon je suis moi je pense
que quand on est dans une course contre
la montre il faut être pragmatique donc
que les polonais rajoute des éoliennes
pour remplacer leurs centrales à charbon
je suis tout à fait pour
en attendant un jour de remplacer la
totalité et charbon fonctionne en moins
plus éoliennes part du bas carbone
pilotable parce que sinon ils s'en
sortiront jamais bien d'accord et du bas
carbone pilotable c'est bien simple il
ya que deux modes il hydroélectricité
nucléaire et sauf à faire du stockage à
grande échelle mais je ne suis pas sûre
qu'on y arrivera dans les délais donc ça
peut être un débat aussi je n'en connais
que deux hydroélectricité nucléaire donc
tant qu'on est en norvège on peut faire
que de l'hydro donc on peut faire 100%
renouvelable dont j'étais absolument
rien contre 100% où est née en norvège
donc c'est très bien qu'il l'ait fait je
suis ravi qu'il l'ait fait on peut faire
pas loin de ça en autriche ou en suisse
par contre dans le plat pays qui est
celui de brel et en pologne qui est
quand même pas très très montagneuse
avec la population qui sont aujourd'hui
et s'ils veulent garder quelques
bagnoles et quelques immeubles ils n'y
arriveront jamais juste avec des
éoliennes et du stockage de la faim ou
en tout cas pas dans les délais donc
faut être pragmatique c'est juste ça que
je suis en train de dire qu'en france on
remplace du nucléaire part de l'éolien
et du solaire me paraît être une
diversion de moyens délétère donc ça
nous a fait ça nous fait ça de sa
augmenté risque concours parce que cet
argent là et les cervelles on les
obtient les n'utilise pas à replanter
des forêts avant quelques rames comme au
canada parce qu'elles vont aussi devoir
passer 50 degrés en france les forêts
d'accord on les occupe pas à construire
des pistes cyclables pour que les gens
puissent rouler en vélo électrique ou
pas au lieu de rouler en voiture
électrique ou pas du reste parce que
vélo électrique c'est quand même 50 fois
moins de métal est cinquante fois moins
de capacité de batterie qu'une bagnole
donc partout dans le périurbain où on
peut faire des trucs en vélo électrique
c'est le déploiement du vélo électrique
qui permet de se passer de la voiture le
plus vite possible
bon donc encore une fois je suis
pragmatique moi je veux qu'on aille vite
j'ai dit j'ai écrit un milliard de fois
que j'étais très favorable à la pompe à
chaleur et je pense par contre que dans
le bâtiment vouloir sur isolé dans la
rénovation thermique est une ânerie
aussi parce que c'est une dilapidation
moyen sûr qu'il faut décarbonés le
vecteur faux faux divisé par deux en
gros la consommation par plus est
décarbonée le vecteur je suis d'accord
avec le fait que dans certains secteurs
on peut aller plus vite le 3 % par an
mais parce qu'on ne peut parler dans
tous les secteurs aussi vite c'est pour
ça que pour l'économie dans son ensemble
a redit 1 ou un ennemi d'accord parce
que autant décarbonés rapide
chauffage on va y arriver des carboni
rapidement la production d'acier c'est
avec une autre paire de manches dans les
domaines dans lesquels on est déjà très
optimisé par exemple les camions dans
les camions frappe à 3% par an parce
qu'un moteur de camion s'est déjà hyper
optimisé parce que le carburant c'est
25% des coûts du transporteur donc ça
dépend vraiment des secteurs il ya des
secteurs encore une fois dans lequel oui
on peut faire 3 4% par an pas de
problème avec ça le mais j'insiste je
pense qu'aujourd'hui ce qui nous manque
c'est d'être pragmatique et on sera
pragmatique le jour où on aura la bonne
hiérarchie des risques en tête
on ne comprend pas que en fait avec les
risques liés aux limites planétaires
global on est en train de se diriger
vers la barbarie et donc on est en train
de chipoter pinailler sur des machins
des trucs et des bidules qui sont des
luxes de nantis mais enfin je veux dire
le problème il est pas là on est dans
une course contre la montre pour
préserver l'absence de guerre une
espérance de vie à peu près correct et
le fait que les gens mangent à leur faim
c'est de ça dont on est en train de
parler on n'est pas en train de parler
de bon alors est ce qui nous manque là
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec thomas
olivier si la pédagogie du problème la
capacité à le faire comprendre on peut
malheureusement pas compter sur la
classe politique qui en démocratie est
essentiellement démagogiques pour faire
la pédagogie du problème et on peut
difficilement compter sur les acteurs
qu'on pas intérêt à ce qu'on change les
règles du jeu pour le faire donc il
reste pas énormément de gens aient enfin
pour finir cet inventaire désagréable on
ne peut pas non plus compter sur les
journalistes parce que ils sont pas là
pour faire de l'éducation des masses
ils sont là pour vous parler de match de
foot donc le baril sont pas là pour ça
donc ils ne font pas quand est-ce qu'ils
le font ne font pas regardons la manière
dont on parle de jeu frédéric messier
ses poches et ses chaussettes je suis
des liens pour ça que j'ai une ong
d'information je suis délibérément
désagréable mais je jeu pendant
longtemps j'ai monté avec un copain
journalistes une école d'hiver à
combloux pour essayer de former des
rédacteurs en chef à ces questions lors
pas vu une différence majeure dans le
traitement de l'information y compris
avec les gens qui sont passés chez nous
donc on va dire qu'il y en a 5 % qui ont
un peu bougé mais donc il ya le système
est très inertielle et puis ils
dépendent de leurs recettes
publicitaires quand ils en dépendent pas
ils dépendent de leur audience et du
coup de l'ego des journalistes qui ont
besoin de l'audience fabre à knokke le
système est très rigide et en fait le
vrai danger je le vois là c'est à dire
que là où je rejoins tout à fait au top
à olivier sait que le vrai danger c'est
la grande difficulté qu'on a
à faire passer une pédagogie du problème
sa juste place dans la hiérarchie des
risques concours les capacités des
vraies et les fausses capacité d'action
qu'on a et le fait d'avoir une attitude
essentiellement pragmatique pour finir
sur la taxe je pense que la taxe elle
marche bien dans les pays des sens très
libéraux
typiquement la grande bretagne elle
marche moins bien dans les pays des sens
plus planificateur typiquement la france
donc ça dépend à quoi est elle marche
beaucoup mieux dans le secteur be to be
professionnelle que dans le secteur du
consommateur final donc la taxe carbone
appliquée à la production électrique en
grande bretagne a fait des merveilles et
si on voulait bien transformer le
système européen de quotas en vraie taxe
c'est à dire avec un prix de réserve aux
enchères qui croise tous les ans et une
prune qui croise tous les ans si on
respecte pas ses quotas donc en fait on
en fait une vraie taxe ça produirait des
miracles parce que dans ces domaines là
on peut embaucher des armées de
consultants venant de chez carbone 4
pour faire des pas de calcul au centime
près et en disant à à 100,20 100 euros
et 20 centimes la tonne de co2 là j'ai
intérêt à faire tel investissement dans
mon four à ciment que je n'ai pas
intérêt à faire à 99 euros et 80
centimes
donc si on a la visibilité sur le prix
et une armée de consultants dans le
secteur professionnel c'est un très bon
système pour le consommateur final je
suis maintenant convaincu qu'il faut
passer par la réglementation ça va
beaucoup plus vite donc je préfère de
très loin un système disant interdiction
d'avoir une chaudière à fuel dans les
deux ans interdiction de garder une
chaudière à fuel dans les quatre ans
sauf que la collectivité si vous n'avez
pas les moyens de la changer vous paye
le changement voilà donc plutôt que de
faire taxe un dividende ont fait
réglementation et ses aides
je préfère de très loin un système de
cette nature c'est simple et de bon goût
c'est lisible on comprend où on va on
sait qui on doit former pour faire la
transformation
alors qu'avec la taxe on sait pas ce que
les gens vont choisir comme solution
donc on peut préparer ni la production
ni la formation et les compétences donc
pour le consommateur final de très très
loin
maintenant je préfère et la taxe elle
est là pour éviter l'effet rebond mais
c'est pas le déterminant principal de la
politique n'était pas en un masque c'est
tu vois que tu aimes l'économie c'est ce
que j'avais dit bédard pour fait bien
d'ailleurs je suis très fashion
là je pense alors pour le coup quand on
lit vraiment dans les détails le rapport
blanchard tyrol c'est exactement ce
qu'ils disent eux ils disent alors il y
la taxe et plus oui il détaille pas
tellement plus ils disent
alors après si tu veux tu as la rue
l'économie c'est pas très pragmatique
sur le plus c'est ça que je veux dire
oui parce que si tu veux c'est pas leur
boulot et le boulot dans l'économie
c'est de se dire la solution la plus
efficiente c'est à dire qu'il nous
permet de parce que l'arbitrage dans tu
viens de parler c'est efficient c'est à
dire c'est ça qui nous amène à faire les
bons choix au bon moment donc à réduire
le coût de la transition pour la société
et donc l'argument des économies c'est
dire on va mettre la taxe ça va envoyer
les bonnes incitations et je pense pas
que ce soit un problème de libéralisme
ou 2 ou 2 ou de diriger le fond c'est
juste un problème de bon sens de
d'efficacité et après tu as raison pour
des secteurs sur lesquels on pense que
la taxe va être trop lente à agir ou va
pas le faire tout de suite où tu as
raison puis allez ça va créer de
l'incertitude en ce qui va se passer on
peut très bien mettre des normes et là
pour le coup est encore une fois je
pense que les gens sont à leur place
blanchard tyrol c'est pas des
chauffagistes donc ils savent pas sur
quel point met l'accent en revanche ils
disent c'est sûr qu'avec la taxe on va
pas tout faire je pense qu'il ya deux
points qui sont importants et je
voudrais revenir là dessus hein c'est la
redistribution quand tu dis on va donner
de l'argent aux gens quand on leur
talent hors économise quand on leur fait
changer de chaudière
j'en étais dire d'accord il ya eu
quantitative easing des tombereaux
d'argent public d'argent de la banque
qui se déverse m'enfin on sent bien que
les dettes sont importantes donc
l'intérêt la taxe il faut pas
sous-estimer le pouvoir redistributif de
mettre une taxe est d'utiliser cet
argent pour financer la transition
le deuxième aspect qui me semble
important avec une taxe carbone c'est
qu'elle elle nous permet d'empaqueter
nos voisins c'est à dire qu'à partir du
moment où on dit on va faire une taxe
carbone aux frontières
les chinois qui ont qui voient ça se dit
si je veux continuer à exporter en
europe
je suis obligé de payer est de créer une
taxe chez moi et donc pour le coup tu
peux non seulement un impact est ton en
environnement et tu peut impacter le
reste est le troisième point qui me
semble important puits qui rejoint
beaucoup des discussions qu'on a qu'on
va dans leur apporte blanchard tyrol il
parle beaucoup de gouvernance
ellis pour que tout ça marche il faut
créer les institutions indépendantes et
transparentes dans laquelle les citoyens
auront confiance parce qu'ils se diront
s'il ya une taxe carbone c'est pas fait
pour ans pour enrichir les banquiers etc
mais ça sera administré par une agence
indépendante transparente et je pense
que là et ça rejoint beaucoup d'aidé des
sujets qu'on a sur la transparence de la
gouvernance est et ce qui nous en tant
que moi en tant que scientifique et puis
les cadres d'edf qui nous les employés
d'edf qui nous affole c'est qu'il ya pas
de n'y a pas de transparence dans la
gouvernance le problème du changement
climatique et que c'est pas assez bien
bien expliquer puis qui a pas
d'institution qui soit vraiment
transparente dans la vie sur laquelle on
puisse s'appuyer et c'est ce que je
voulais je pense qu'effectivement on a
vraiment besoin de cette acceptabilité
sociale et pour cela il faut la
pédagogie il faut les bons instruments
il faut les bonnes politiques publiques
je vous propose qu'on passe aux
questions du public justement parce que
ils doivent tous tombent et elles sont
passionnantes et ça va vous permettre
sans doute encore une fois de creuser et
donc je vais prendre rome une première
quelle analyse faites-vous sur les
conclusions du récent rapport de l'eeie
concernant les tensions à venir sur les
matières premières qui veut prendre
quelqu'un allait jean-marc avoue le nerf
ben en fait quand on puisse continuer à
parler d'économie il ya quelque chose
que beaucoup de gens n'arrivent pas à
comprendre facilement c'est que quand on
a une matière première qui est essentiel
au fonctionnement de l'économie
je peux parler du pétrole par exemple ce
sens pétrole n'y a pas de transport et
sans transports n'est pas d'économie je
peux parler de l'acier aussi aujourd'hui
à de l'acier absolument partout sans
acier ont fait à peu près rien et bien
si cette matière devient plus rare le
prix de cette matière ne peut pas
augmenter indéfiniment
parce qu'en fait si cette matière
devient plus rare l'économie elle-même
se porte moins bien donc en fait on a un
sujet sur le pib
si une matière essentielle à l'économie
fait défaut à cause de face et ce que
j'avais essayé d'expliquer tout à
l'heure c'est une ressource essentielle
et donc on peut assez facilement
théorisé que quand une matière
essentielle commencent à se raréfier en
fait son prix n'est ni durablement élevé
ni durablement bas mais durablement
volatile et donc c'est juste ça que les
yeux est en train de rappeler pour moi
donc après un pétrole bas rhin pétrole
aux puits après un pétrole il y aura de
nouveau un pétrole mappy etc
voilà c'est aussi aussi bête que ça
alors pourquoi est ce que les matières
premières peuvent faire un peu plus
défaut parce qu'il ya en fait il ya une
oscillation
d'abord il ya un an pour certaines
matières pas tout mais il ya des
possibilités d'en extraire qui se
raréfie je vais donner un exemple quand
on a commencé à extraire du cuivre de la
mine de rio tinto en espagne je crois
que la teneur en métal du minerai était
aux alentours de 20%
non aujourd'hui la teneur en métal des
mines exploitées en moyenne dans le
monde c'est 0 4%
non donc ça ça veut dire qu'il faut plus
d'énergie pour extraire du cuivre du
minerai donc ça veut dire que par
construction c'est plus cher enfin ou en
tout cas ça demande plus de ressources
et si ces ressources valent plus cher
c'est plus cher et a même système quand
on va exploiter le gaz du château lui
manque et en fait je vais je vais aller
un peu plus loin plus généralement dans
le raisonnement en fait ce qui va
marquer économiquement la raréfaction
d'une ressource sait pas que son prix
monte ou que son prix baissent c'est que
la quantité d'investissement qu'il faut
mettre sur la table pour en extraire une
unité additionnel augmente et en fait
c'est aimer dos qui m'avait dit ça la
seule fois de ma vie où j'ai rencontré
donc le fait à cette remarque est
effectivement donc en fait la part dont
le vrai marqueur de la raréfaction
progressive d'une ressource sait pas que
son prix montent ou descendent
c'est ce qui va se passer quand tu mets
un coup dans la 105 ou dans l'autre
c'est qu'en fait le capex enfin le
capital qu'il faut mettre sur la table
en termes de ressources physiques et
donc de coût le plus souvent qu'il faut
mettre sur la table pour extraire un
baril additionnel une tonne de cuivre
etc augmentent sans cesse et on dans un
certain nombre de domaines on est déjà
en train de constater cette évolution
est donc ça veut juste dire que ça
préfigure un moment où des ressources
essentielles pour l'économie ils vont
devenir moins facile à extraire et donc
leur prix va aussi y est voilà donc
après les primes rabat les prix
remontent
c'est toujours un peu la même chose
c'est de se dire oui c'est vrai mara
pour le coup c'est l'ingénieur qui
répondra à partir du moment où on voit
qui a des ressources qui viennent
structurellement plus rares en général
quand on essaye de les recycler moi j'ai
travaillé un moment dans l'aluminium et
c'était assez marrant parce que les
canettes d'aluminium le pourcentage
canettes recyclées est proportionnel au
prix de l'aluminium sur les marchés et
plus zen mécanique c'est mécanique c'est
à dire que quand lesquels l'école prix
de l'aluminium augmente
tu vois des recycleurs du ferrailleur
ramasser les canettes et kylie kylie
kylie ford quand le prix de l'aluminium
et robin tu vois plus gros site a donc
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
l'analyse de jean marc le seul bémol que
je mettrais c'est de dire il ya quand
même le système s'adapte et c'est pas un
truc d'économie c'est vraiment un truc
d'un chat c'est à dire que si les prix
on voit bien qu'il ya que le pétrole ou
le nickel que le cobalt 9e durablement
plus rare et qu'on a de plus en plus de
mal à le sortir les ingénieurs on dira
temps on va sur une solution pour
utiliser un peu moins 10 15 e bengo
balle pour recycler le nickel cobalt
qu'on a c'est apprendre de l'énergie ont
recyclé pétrole c'est plus du vent voici
que je voulais c'était dur c'est pour ça
qu'on va faire va faire du on va faire
d'autres doutent mais tu as raison mais
c'est pour ce à quoi on va faire
d'autres énergies du nucléaire des
relevés mais moi je pense qu'à une
capacité d'adaptation qui est important
dans l'appareil industriel
on le voit dans toutes les industries
dans lesquelles on travaille les gens
sont malins quand les prix d'une
ressource augmente quand le coût
d'extraction augmente les gens substitut
re sic enfin ils regardent pas juste le
prix monte si je peux me permettre la
limite quand même à la substitution le
parce que les facteurs de substitution
sont pas toujours aussi simples d'abord
les propriétés chimiques des éléments
sont pas substituables et puis après on
peut créer une tension sur une autre
source qui est très très forte en jeu
donner deux exemples
il faut 50 à 100 fois plus de métal pour
faire un kilowattheure solaire que pour
faire un kilowatt heure nucléaire ou
charbon ou gaz de rester pareil electric
1 50 à 100 fois plus c'est pas 10% plus
quoi il faut 1000 fois plus de foncier
mille fois plus pour faire de
l'électricité avec du solaire qu'avec du
nucléaire mille fois plus c'est pas deux
fois plus donc le basculement en fait la
raison pour laquelle on est allé vers
les combustibles fossiles dans l'énergie
c'est parce que c'est extraordinairement
concentré danse hip air facile à stocker
et à transporter comparé aux énergies
renouvelables qui sont diffuses pour
l'essentiel très faste compliqué à
transporter même pour les plus
concentrées d'entre elles notamment le
bois c'est compliqué quand même à
l'époque de la marine à voile de faire
faire voir et je le redis les systèmes
sont pas bouclées c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui un panneau solaire un
panneau pv se fait avec du charbon du
pétrole et du gaz combien vaudra lequel
sera la facilité d'accès un panneau
solaire le jour où la mine devrait être
faite avec du solaire
la métallurgie de base voilà une
fonderie d'aluminium avec des panneaux
solaires à laminoir d'aluminium avec des
panneaux solaires des bateaux pour
transporter l'aluminium sur terre avec
des panneaux solaires et des
tractopelles pour installer les panneaux
avec de l'énergie solaire etc
on en reparlera du prix à mon avis est
évident qu'aujourd'hui on a un artefact
économique qui est que le prix de
production des dispositifs dits
renouvelables hérite de la productivité
issus des combustibles fossiles
donc si donc c'est pour ça que je ne
crois pas du tout aux projections de
prix de l'eeie le jour où je supprime
les combustibles fossiles
le prix sur les panneaux solaires et les
éoliennes fait x 50 absolument évident
pour moi ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est qu'on voit bien que de toute façon
on va devoir transformer la société dans
laquelle on se déclare l'idée c'est pas
de voir de quelle manière on va garder
le modèle dans lequel on sait comment et
dans quelles échelles de temps on va
faire face à ce défi alors du queen's il
ya des pôles des implications politiques
politico sociale évidente et du coup je
vous propose de passer à cette autre
question qui émane du public comment
pensez vous qu'une société démocratique
puisse volontairement organisé la
réduction structurelle du pib
nécessaires pour limiter les émissions
de co2 fâche glaciale alors que là on y
est j'ai une bonne nouvelle la récession
structurels en fait elle a déjà commencé
en europe
quand on regarde le pib vrai les mètres
carrés qui ont construit la production
industrielle qu'on produit pour nous
mêmes et c'est en fait c'est déjà à la
baisse depuis 2007
donc je vous ai entendu plusieurs fois
parlé de cette fameuse année 2007
qu'est ce que vous entendez par là
qu'est ce que vous avez qu'est ce qui
s'est passé en 2007
en fait il s'est passé en 2006 la yole
date de 2008 moi je le date de 2006 mais
reste à peu près il s'est passé le pic
de production du pétrole conventionnel
c'est à dire il s'est passé alors en
europe qui s'est passé d'autres trucs en
plus mais il s'est passé que le pétrole
qu'on extrait des gisements ordinaire
entre guillemets c'est à dire tout ce
qui n'est pas le pétrole de schiste et
les sables bitumineux du canada est
passé par un maximum historique absolu
et depuis ça décline quand on regarde
les zones dans le monde qui produisent
ce pétrole sur toutes les zones sauf les
états unis l'afrique est en déclin
depuis 2009 la mer du nord est en déclin
depuis 2000
la chine est en déclin depuis 2011 la
russie ça y est ils l'ont annoncé aura
passé son pic en 2019
donc il pour s'être passé en 2021 mais à
cause du co lead c'est voilà donc en
fait l'essentiel des pays dans le monde
ont passé leur pic de production sur ces
gisements là le challenge donc le
pétrole de schiste aux états unis qui
est un pétrole de fonds de tiroir c'est
un mauvais pétrole il faut en gros
consacré à l'extraction de ce pétrole
un quart de l'énergie qu'on obtient
alors que sur le pétrole conventionnel
on est à quelques pour cent donc c'est
pas du tout un pétrole sans compter la
dégradation environnementale
celle là est pas terrible parce qu'en
fait on travaux fracture à 3000 mètres
sous terre c'est parmi nos jeunes il
faut pas plus il faut pas plus d'eau
pour exploiter ce pétrole là que pour
exploiter du charbon par exemple les
mines de charbon on utilise des
quantités d'eau faramineuses pour laver
de charbon donc non les la presse s'est
focalisée sur des problèmes qui n'en
sont pas le vrai problème c'est que
c'est une énergie fossile
le deuxième vrai problème c'est qu'il ya
une occupation en surface absolument
faramineuses parce qu'il fallait faire
un puits tous les 500 mètres de la
taille d'un terrain de foot donc quand
vous regardez les photos aériennes des
champs de pétrole de schiste aux états
unis si hallucinant enfin je veux dire
c'est des constellations depuis et c'est
en termes d'artificialisation alors ils
font ça deux ans n'est pas vraiment ça
les endroits où ils poussent 3 arbustes
donc on s'en fout un peu
enfin si vous nous on avait voulu faire
ça dans les cévennes s'était passé
n'était pas la même histoire
là bas c'est tout plat donc faire des
pistes on peut pas faire deux oléoducs
parce que la production est trop faible
donc tous évacués par camions donc il
faut faire des pistes qui relie tous les
puits et tous les 500 mètres
donc en gros c'est presque comme faire
une vie dans terme d'artificialisation
on n'aurait pas fait ça en europe donc
c'est très particulier aux états unis
puis en plus le droit minier s'en mêle
enfin bon prix il n'empêche qu'ils ont
j'avais gagné un radier avec ce pétrole
de schiste c'est à dire que en termes de
cash flow ils ont toujours été négatif
depuis le début de cette industrie il
n'y a que quand ils ont arrêté de faire
des puits partout et que la production a
décliné que sur les sur la production
déclinante restantes ils sont bien
gagner de l'argent c'est quand même très
drôle donc en fait on ne peut gagner de
l'argent sur ce truc là quand la
production baisse bombardements
donc tout ça mis bout à bout c'est que
la production de pétrole mondiale
conventionnelle a décliné à partir de
2008 le chéneau il était un phénomène
essentiellement américains donc la
quantité de pétrole disponible pour les
européens c'est vise à baisser à partir
de 2007 la mer du nord a passé son prog
son pic de production en gaz en 2005
or 60 % du gaz européen venait de la mer
du nord à cette époque là et enfin le
charbon européen est en déclin depuis
les années 60 parce que ça fait deux
siècles comptable dans notre charbon et
le charbon voyage peut contrairement à
ce qu'on peut penser qu'il n'y a que 10
% du charbon mondiale ne servant pas la
métallurgie qui passe une frontière
entre le pays de production et le pays
de consommation c'est une énergie
domestique essentiellement donc l'europe
est aujourd'hui en déclin sur le charbon
en déclin sur le pétrole en déclin sur
le gaz climat ou pas climat et l'un
d'eux veut trop peu c'est de dire que la
croissance n'existe plus entraînants et
en fait la seule croissance qu'on a
depuis c'est de la fausse croissance
encore une fois c'est l'inflation
d'actifs et le quantitative easing créer
de l'inflation comme il se doit
lorsque leia de la création monétaire
mais comme l'argent ne quitte pas les
investisseurs qui cédèrent les banques
qui reçoivent cet argent est bien que
font les banques avec elles ne
distribuent pas aux épargnants elles
sont à sont pas besoin il suffit qu'ils
octroient des crédits pour ça elles
investissent et donc cette inflation au
lieu de concerner les montres et les
paires de baskets concerne les trucs qui
s'achète pour des investisseurs
donc des oeuvres d'art des entreprises
des mètres carrés des forêts des terres
agricoles en fait tout ça voit son prix
exploser prix des terres agricoles dans
le monde a été multiplié par six en quoi
12 ans 15 ans hallucinant et du coup je
reviens à la question du public sur la
société démocrate solvant dont il y
avait une question accidenté pourquoi
2007 oui il y tout à fait né et qui
étaient majeurs d'abord parce que en
fait aujourd'hui on n'a même plus besoin
de vendre la décroissance au public
français on a juste besoin de lui faire
comprendre que c'est déjà la succession
et qu'on n'a plus besoin de la vendre
c'est elle est déjà là elle est déjà en
route on la maquille avec des machins
mais en fait elle est déjà là on voit
bien aussi dans la vie des jeunes par
exemple la colocation est plus en plus
fréquentes la colocation c'est de la
sobriété
parce qu'une seule salle de bain pour 3
c'est plus sobre que d'avoir chacun sa
salle de bains chacun ses chiottes et
chacun sa cuisine c'est là vous voyez le
c'est déjà de la sobriété dans la
transformation des usages on ne voyait
on y est on y est déjà pour partie
donc ça c'est la bonne nouvelle ça veut
dire que les gens se rendent compte que
c'est possible puisqu'on est déjà en
train de s'organiser comme ça alors la
décroissance est dramatique
si vos revenus baissent et que vos
charges ne baisse pas mais si vos
charges baissent à mesure que vos
revenus baissent on peut discuter
peut-être donc en fait si on quitte
l'indicateur monétaire j'y reviens parce
que c'était ça mon point tout à l'heure
et qui ont dit physiquement les gens ont
besoin d'un toit ils ont besoin d'espoir
ils ont besoin d'un job et ils ont
besoin d'avoir confiance pour leurs
gamins peut-être que l'on peut parler
d'argent une fois qu'on a traité ces
problèmes là et donc c'est pour ça que
je pense que la question de la
décroissance dans une démocratie il faut
pas la vendre comme tels parce que c'est
compliqué par contre il ya quelque chose
qui ressemble s'appelle sobriété ça les
gens commencent à voilà et le fait qu'
il ya des tas d'éléments pas économiques
sur lesquels on peut gagner quand on
perd sur les éléments économiques ça
commence à faire son chemin aussi par
exemple vous faites du vélo plutôt que
l'électrique plutôt que de faire de la
voiture est bien certes vous avez pu
votre voiture mais vous êtes un peu plus
en forme
vous êtes en meilleure santé vous allez
avoir beaucoup de santé qui vont baisser
ou enfin ou alors il ya d un certain
nombre d'éléments que vous vous êtes de
meilleure humeur que les plus en forme
vous n'êtes pas coincés dans les
bouchons ça vous rend aussi de meilleure
humeur donc vous avez un certain nombre
davantage que vous y gagnez etc des
avantages non économique mais c'est des
avantages réels
donc le jeu je pense que la solde pour
répondre à cette question la seule façon
de faire passer ça en démocratie c'est
de paradoxalement quitté le débat tobin
a fait vient de dépasser et d'arrêter
d'avoir un débat purement économique et
le pib il monte il monte il descend il
descend on s'en fout la seule chose
qu'il faut c'est que le système soit
ajustée pour savoir gérer la baisse
comme la housse est aujourd'hui en fait
il n'est pas capable de s'ajuster quand
les recettes baissent
c'est ça son problème donc il va falloir
voir ça comme olivier avant d'en fait ce
que je veux bien faire pour qu'on avance
c'est juste je trouvais intéressant
parce que vous avez parlé donc de
l'aspect un peu désincarnées de ses
réflexions et c'est pour le coup le
groupe edf vous êtes dans le réel dans
le concret puisque vous êtes un groupe
industriel vous
devait faire face à voile à des
stratégies à long terme là dessus et je
vois qu'il ya cette question qui à mon
avis beaucoup vous intéresser que
peuvent faire les collaborateurs depuis
l'intérieur une approche bottom up pour
convaincre leurs comex le management de
transformer leur business model
immédiatement entre parenthèses pas à 10
ou 20 ans pour par exemple abandonné
tout de suite les produits
vachalé hautement carbonées boum on est
dedans alors il ya la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'il ya pas besoin de commettre
veut convaincre le comex du groupe edf
on a et puis c'est pas des c'est bien
parce que c'est bien de le dire du
prénommé c'est bien le dire et puis
c'est pas des paroles en l'air il ya la
stratégie du groupe edf est très claire
on va être un intergiciel décarbonés on
va aller décarbonés chez nos clients
on veut on veut produire à la fois
d'électricité décarbonée chez nous on
veut accompagner nos clients dans north
décarbonation on n'a pas de produits
carbonés vache à lait notre produit là
où on a nos profits basse et dans la
production d'électricité décarbonée
nucléaire d'une robe l'âme ça doit être
touche pas eu 81 85 % de nos profits il
ya un peu les italiens mais quand tu
regardes en pourcentage c'est quand même
pas énorme géré il ya encore des
délégations business dans ton sévère
mais par rapport
et ça c'est un truc qui est un point qui
est super important par rapport à
d'autres groupes industriels nous tous
notre cash to know capex y vendant le
décarbonée on finance donc le p r à
flamanville en finance le p r hpc on
essaie de faire d'autres se perd en
angleterre en étant né en inde pour des
contrats pour faire 6 e p r on discute
avec le gouvernement polonais comme
gouverneur cheikh on est partout sur les
renouvelables
on est en train de finir un champ au
large de saint nazaire en a gagné hier
une enchère aux états unis au new jersey
pour 1500 mégawatts
donc les milliards de capex qu'on fait
on les fait dans le décarbonée c'est de
l'éolien je sais de l'éolien marin auch
1500 mégawatts au large du new jersey
donc donc la stratégie du groupe edf
elle éclaire et les actions du groupe
edf sont claires après j'aimerais
revenir sur le
c'est cette histoire de pib il ya il ya
plusieurs sujets qui sont âprement hyper
important le premier c'est de la
sobriété c'est quelque chose de très
important qui effectivement plus
compréhensif plus est plus aisé à
accepter que la décroissance il ya
beaucoup d' usage je pense qu'il ya une
différence entre dire on va faire du
vélo électrique dans les villes parce
que 80 % des voyages de mobilité des
registres dans le rapport du chiffre
sont des trucs de moins de 5 km
franchement 5 km dans paris avec un vélo
électrique ça c'est aussi bien qu'avec
une voiture pas de souci ça c'est pour
moi c'est de la sobriété
on va vite dans les appartements
éventuellement un petit plus petits les
enfants de toute façon j'aime bien
rester avec leurs parents les parents
aiment bien garder leurs enfants
on va partager un peu plus longtemps ça
c'est une chose très claire en revanche
de dire on va plus avoir d'énergie et
donc encore une décroissance brutale de
lélex de l'économie de 3 4 5 % par an
pendant une période longue ça pour moi
c'est pas de la sobriété c'est autre
chose et ça la plupart dès lors c'est
pas des économistes la plupart des
scientifiques te dis c'est compliqué à
avoir une période longue de décroissance
de l'économie je pense que c'est là où
tu voulais au début sans dans un système
démocratique dans une société stable et
je pense que là ce qui nous ce qui nous
anime c'est de dire on ne veut pas aller
là nous ce qui nous a laissé dire on
veut pas se retrouver dans cette
situation à faire face à cinq ou dix ou
vingt ans de décroissance force et c'est
pas prendre le volant parisse et -3% de
peep parents donc on peut plus payer
d'avantagé là dessus c'est très
compliqué on veut pas aller là donc il
faut décarbonés aujourd'hui parce que il
est urgent éviter le choc et avoir la
maîtrise de cette transformation c'est
un peu ça en fait si je suis connaîtra
je pense que c'est ce qui nous anime ce
qu'on essaye de faire
oui je pense qu'on a quand même une
partie à laquelle on échappera pas alors
peut-être juste encore une question un
peu technique mais quels indicateurs
économiques pour remplacer le pibe si
c'est nécessaire d'en avoir un c'est pas
nécessaire de le remplacer c'est
nécessaire de faire
c'est nécessaire va voir des plans pour
l'avenir qui ne présuppose pas qu'il
augmente c'est très différent
le jeu prendre un exemple idiot issus de
notre propre vie et je vais prendre un
toujours un exemple idiot c'est notre
puissance musculaire la puissance
musculaire d'un individu elle augmente
entre 0 et 15 20 ans puis après ça se
passe moins bien
enfin bourreau c'est stable pendant un
certain temps et puis à un moment ça
baisse bon est ce qu'au moment où ça se
met à baisser c'est un drame pas
nécessairement
ça serait un drame si on disait il faut
que ça augmente indéfiniment jusqu'au
jour de ma mort pour les gens qui
meurent en montagne ces scripts qui
passe quand même mais par contre les
sinon tant que ça baisse pas dans des
proportions dramatiques en bon incommode
en cours un peu moins vite j'ai quand
même pas très grave si on court un peu
moins vivre donc là c'est exactement
pareil en ce qui concerne le pipe je
pense que ce qui faut c'est avoir des
plans pour l'avenir qui ne présuppose
pas qu'il augmente en permanence alors
là où je suis d'accord c'est qu'il ya
des cas de figure c'est plus compliqué
de dire à des retraités vous allez
retourner vivre chez hugo boss
parce que ça vous évitera de payer votre
logement que de dire aujourd'hui vous
allez au boulot en bagnole allez-y donc
en vélo donc c'est évident qu'il faut
commencer par des trucs qui sont plus
simples il ya les papas fois voilà après
si les retraités vous leur dites aussi
alors cessé il ya besoin
d'accompagnement pour tout ça j'en ai
parfaitement conscience donc je peux
enfin dire il ya qu'à faut qu'on mais
vous leur dites vous avez maintenant que
les enfants sont partis vous habiter
dans un logement qui est trop grand pour
vous donc la société va vous faciliter
la vie pour vous alliez dans un machin
plus petit et donc on va éviter de
construire des logements nouveaux juste
parce que vous vous restez dans un
logement trop grand c'est aussi une
forme de sobriété bon est ce que c'est
un truc dramatique
cela dépend je veux dire donc voilà donc
ce qui est sûr c'est que tant qu'on n'y
a pas réfléchi on va rien trouvé donc
moi mon premier combat il est de dire
faisons au moins l'effort de réfléchir à
la façon dont sont s'organise dans ce
genre de contexte à voir ce que les gens
sont facilement prêt à accepter moins
facilement prêt à accepter ce qu'ils ont
compris la situation future pas compris
de la situation future et c'est là où je
suis moins serein que thomas olivier
c'est que je pense que les 50 degrés au
canada le mit
de réfugiés syriens et autres
plaisanteries et les -40% qu'on a eu en
france sur les patates ou le blé c'est
juste un apéritif
donc il faut bien qu'on comprenne que à
un moment dire on leur a pas parce qu'on
veut pas c'est pas ça qui va se passer
on va la voir de toute façon mais d'une
façon non gérés bon on va commencer le
maghreb va s'assécher
aujourd'hui les pays du maghreb
nourrissent leurs populations parce
qu'ils ont des soldes exportateurs sur
des trucs qui vont pas durer le tourisme
tourisme quand il aura plus de pétrole
et puis d'avion c'est fini l'algérie son
pétrole et son gaz pétrole et le gaz il
sait plus ils sont en train de baisser
ils ont ils sont incapables d'avoir une
agriculture autosuffisante dans ces pays
là en plus le pays est en train de
s'assécher
donc il n'est que d'attendre et on va
avoir quelques dizaines de millions de
personnes qui voudront aller voir de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée le temps
qu'il fait c'est juste une affaire et je
ferais la même chose à leur place donc
je suis pas du tout en train de les
accuser de quoi que ce soit bon et ça
c'est juste un élément de
déstabilisation par vidéo donc l'idée
qu'on va pouvoir vivre à l'avenir dans
un monde stable dans lequel on n'a qu'un
seul problème à gérer qui est
d'installer des éoliennes j'y crois pas
je crois que malheureusement on va vivre
dans un monde dans lequel l'instabilité
et va devenir la règle et que dans ce
contexte là même si on la veut pas la
décroissance du pib
on va se farcir donc le jeudi
réfléchissons maintenant où on a encore
un peu le temps de le faire
on n'est pas encore à la rue on est
encore un peu confortable à quelque
chose qui n'a pas besoin de cette
croissance et qui est capable
d'encaisser des chocs
parce que malheureusement on n'a pas
fini d'en encaisser voilà c'est ça mon
propos donc je suis pas en train de dire
que je souhaite à tout je suis pas un
col absolue
je suis pas en train de me délecter avec
gourmandise du fait que le système
risque de s'effondrer
non je dis justement puisque c'est un
risque essayons de nous couvrir contre
ce risque
et plus on anticipe et plus on y
réfléchit à l'avance est en général
mieux on se porte
voilà donc c'est ça mon c'est ça mon
sujet et donc faisons l'effort d'y
réfléchir avec un cahier des charges qui
est celui qu'on va vraisemblablement
avoir devant nous que ça nous plaise ou
pas qui est une diminution de moyens
parce que la terre est finie et que
c'est comme ça
j'aimerais oui ya deux points le temps
file vite donc il va falloir qu'on aille
plus vite et on va pas prendre encore
deux caisses
d'une réponse de réponse une première
sur la sur l'urgence et je pense qu'on
est vraiment d'accord là dessus et je
veux que ce soit clair pour tout le
monde nous groupe edf
moi en tant que scientifique on est
d'accord sous fait qu'on n'a pas le plus
vraiment beaucoup le temps et c'est pour
ça qu'on insiste un peu lourdement mais
elle appelle à répétition c'est la mère
de la pédagogie pour remettre un prix du
carbone maintenant maintenant maintenant
qui va commencer à faire basculer les
gens parce que et ça c'est une
conviction l'intérêt du prix c'est que
ça n'est pas que c'est pas coercitif
dire aux personnes âgées la société va
vous trouver un logement
ça fait à exagérer un petit peu mais ça
fait un peu nord corée du nord quoi en
revanche le prix augmente parce que si
parce que ça et donc vous naturellement
vous allez changer votre comportement
c'est important et je pense que ça c'est
différent et ça je pense que c'est un
point important nous c'est pour ça qu'on
insiste pour le prix du carbone parce
que ça transfert aux citoyens la
responsabilité de leurs actes et de
leurs décisions
mais enfin juste un point pour finir
parce que là tu vas adorer le pib n'est
plus la mesure utilisé par les
économistes pour mesurer le bien-être à
iliad et dénoue les nouv la nouvelle
réflexion économique
d'ailleurs qui qui parapsy les mêmes
auteurs qui ont commencé à travailler
après le rapport meadows dans les années
70 ils ont réfléchi à une façon
d'incorporer les ressources naturelles
épuisables dans les modèles de
croissance et donc à leur rapport
dasgupta qui a été publié en 2000 21
février 2021
c'est toute une théorie c'est toute une
conception économie qui dit en fait le
pib sa mesure juste les flux marchande
est bien la vraie mesure de dévolution
d'une région d'un pays d'une année sur
l'autre
ça prend en compte à la fois les biens
marchands mais aussi l'évolution des
ressources naturelles et donc si on a
pris plus de biens marchands et ça
rejoint un peu ce que tu disais tout à
l'heure mais que pour produire ces biens
marchands on a détruit plus de
ressources naturelles et ben le
l'indicateur global
il a baissé parce que ça a coûté plus en
ressources naturelles et ressources
naturelles dans l'or dans cette
définition on attrape tout on attrape
les stocks d'eau propre
les stocks des radios diversité ça nous
a coûté plus en terme de biodiversité
que ce que ça nous a rapporté ben on a
baissé notre bien-être
donc tu vois l'économie avance bien et
progresse ainsi baissé de cette
importance
bien sûr comme vous êtes
pédagogue une réponse très courte juste
quelle est la différence entre des
croissance et récession à une récession
et une décroissance du pib
c'est bon bah oui c'est sa définition
ok alors la récession c'est temporaire
ladd et quand on parle de décroissance
c'est quelque chose de plus la lanterne
la récession c'est attaque tac tac
prouve c'est un fait 3 kms d'affilée sa
baisse et après ça repart la récession
enfin d'accord en général la récession
quand on le comprend c'est un truc qui
est plutôt temporaire en revanche quand
tu parles de décroissance on a
l'impression à long terme en faire après
amplifié militants à l'écran il ya une
différence entre la définition qui fait
la valeur et le sens qu'on lui donne un
internaute alors moi je parlais juste de
la définition technique il est
techniquement la décroissance et la
baisse du pib et donc c'est quelque
chose que la récession après que dans
les valeurs les gens qui en parlent
disque par ailleurs ça doit être un
souhait ça c'est un sujet oui l'idée
d'acheter anisé la décroissance est cet
autre show moi je permets juste de la
définition technique on est d'accord
allez juste vraiment parce que je trouve
que c'est trop sympa il ya quelqu'un qui
a écrit je valide la position de thomas
olivier lautier c'est que la commune
cassis c'est que ce n'est que la
communication pour le passage à l'action
qui sera un élément clé pour l'avenir
quel serait votre conseil pour accroître
la connaissance au plus vite et on en
terminera par là parce que ça c'est une
solution comment on fait non c'est pas
ma position c'est ce que fait jean marc
pigeon la tête parce que si j'allais
d'accord tous les deux la leur c'est ce
qui fait tous les jours
s'il y avait une solution miracle je
suis désolé de terminer par une note qui
est peut-être pas aussi gai que s'il y
avait une solution miracle on leur a
déjà trop et il n'y a pas de solution
miracle il faut il
répéter répéter répéter ça va pas assez
vite et bien moi je vais essayer de
mettre un tout petit peu plus
d'espérance pour cette conclusion parce
que je pense qu'effectivement on est
dans le moment de la prise de conscience
je pense qu'il ya effectivement une
opinion publique qui est en train de
basculer je pense que la crise sanitaire
la crise coronavirus a aussi beaucoup
permis aux gens de se poser et d'un coût
de réfléchir et donc le meilleur est à
venir en tout cas nous on va continuer
d'y réfléchir ensemble merci beaucoup
cher jean marc le temps file donc on est
arrivé au terme de cette conférence
merci à toutes et à tous pour votre
participation active
cette conférence sera à voir et à revoir
en replay les équipes d'edf vont faire
en sorte de la m de manière disponible
sur un lien youtube vous pourrez ainsi
la partager je pense que ça devrait
animer vos barbecues et apéro de l'été
et puis donc merci merci cher jean-marc
pour votre présence aujourd'hui merci
cher c'est moi olivier les outils on se
retrouve à la rentrée allemand pour la
suite de notre cycle de conférences en
attendant bel été à tous merci beaucoup